okay did you guys get enough food this
week so far yeah that's one thing in DC
does well right okay so thanks for
coming to my session here on
authorization for your web apps and your
web api's my name is Brock Allen I guess
you'd call me an application security
architect I do consulting and help
companies and customers through a
company called Szalai ins and it's
Alliance we have a security practice
where we help our customers with their
you know identity management
architecture getting things like single
sign-on set up and protecting web api's
I also work on something called identity
server which is an open source project
and framework for helping achieve those
architectures and it helps out with
implementing the Open ID Connect and
both two protocols that you would you
know set up if you're building that kind
of architecture and it's really good
about you know kind of giving you
out-of-the-box
authentication and protection for your
api's for the most common scenarios but
it's also very very flexible such that
if you have some you know odd
requirements that it doesn't just kind
of do automatically for you there's
enough extensibility in there where you
can go and and tweak it and get it to do
which what you need to do so for you
know many many years I've been helping
customers with these identity solutions
and when we go into customers obviously
you know identity server right does the
job of the authentication piece and
great your users are logged in to your
apps but once you've done the
authentication piece right you know who
the user is
the obvious next thing or the next
problem that you run into or that your
application is going to want to know is
now what does that user allowed to do
and so you know for a long time
customers have been happy with identity
server and they say that was great you
know easy to put that in get that going
can you got to do the same thing for
authorization to write can we just put
some middleware or something in my
application and you know you just take
care of
sir ization so we've been you know
having customers ask us for this for a
long long time and you know we've built
custom solutions for customers over the
years but we never had anything that
kind of productized it if that made
sense kind of like identity server
product eise's identity so we've been
wanting to work on this for a very long
time and we finally did spent a lot of
time last year thinking about this
problem and we worked on a commercial
product called policy server to help out
with this now this talks not really
about policy server it's about the sort
of the conclusions and the patterns that
we learned while building it in how we
think you should be or how a lot of
applications probably should be modeling
their authorization and so that's pretty
much what we're gonna talk about I
should mention that the policy server is
basically a combination of myself
Michelle LaRue Bustamante who's also
from Szalai ins and Dominic buyer who's
my colleague that I work on with
identity server and the three of us have
been really really you know thinking
about this problem and so again this
talk is basically trying to show you
guys those conclusions that we came to
about the right way to model
authorization in our applications so
policy server is a product that
implements this pattern and it has a
bunch of you know kind of standard
commercial features right centralization
of authorization and multi-tenant
support and administrative UIs for
building policies various other things
auditing multi-tenancy stuff like that
you know commercial stuff we also built
a open source reference implementation
of the exact same pattern as well so
that's actually what I'm gonna be
showing you here is all the samples or
on the open source implementation and
you know so you'll be able to go and
take the samples and run them and get a
feel for the this pattern that were that
we're promoting so we spent you know
last year going around to all of our
customers and trying to you know find
out for them
you know how do you today do
authorization we're trying to kind of
survey and figure out what we would need
to build in to this product and it
actually turns out that you know you go
into a company and they're actually
doing it many different ways even within
the same project they might be doing
authorization a couple different ways so
we you know saw all kinds of different
patterns that the customers were using
roles and permissions are very very
common there's like the notion of Acts
control lists or Ackles that that
companies have kind of invented for
their own you know systems ackles are
kind of like in Windows when you
right-click a file you get the
properties go to the Security tab and
you can based on an individual user or
group you can you know add a permission
like read or write or deny one so you
know there are lots of different ways of
modeling authorization another example
is something called exact Amol so that
was another like something we looked at
is kind of hey is this a good model to
to you know build this this
authorization product and I think when
we looked at exactly well if you guys
ever used exactly anybody I can actually
barely see you guys but so nobody raised
their hand as far as I can tell that
shows me how popular it was right it
really fixed the problem
what exactly was was a extensible access
control markup language so this was kind
of grew out of you know the heyday of
XML you know a long time ago when
everyone thought XML would would solve
all of our problems and the idea was in
exact mo you would model your
authorization rules in this XML dialect
right and as you can imagine it was
incredibly you know verbose the problem
I think that we ran into and by the way
if you haven't heard authorization is
really hard because there are these
variety of ways with exact amal they I
think fell into the trap of trying to do
too much so when thinking about trying
to build a product we're trying to
figure out what we can generalize into a
product you know that it can encapsulate
and provide you this functionality and
there's a blurry line at which point you
cry
so ver and now your authorization logic
is really business logic okay and I
think that's the problem that exact Amal
sort of the trap they fell into is that
they were trying to make you do all of
the authorization in this XML dialect
and so you know you would spew out this
page long XML you know 30 lines of XML
code to model your problem domain your
business domain of your authorization
logic okay and I don't think I want to
model you know my business logic often
this weird DSL version of XML especially
when the business itself is written in
whatever technology you know say c-sharp
and it might just be that much easier to
write that logic in the native
programming environment where the
business logic is so maybe five lines of
c-sharp rather than exporting a bunch of
data sending it over to this exact level
system and having it try to you know run
this rules engine I mean you can kind of
kind of tell how complicated it is when
actually people were building you know
DSL is for exact more like higher order
sort of a tooling to make that smell
easier to write okay so fundamentally
that was the thing we were drugged you
know struggling with was what's the what
can you generalize and put into some
sort of package and make you know give
some amount of security or authorization
into an application and there's some
line at which you cross where you know
that's not really general authorization
instead that's actually the business
logic of your application so actually
that's kind of the conclusion of this
talk thanks for coming right but we you
know we realized there there's several
different layers of authorization and
what we decided to model in the product
that we build was basically using roles
and permissions right it was kind of the
common theme across pretty much every
system that we saw people understood it
and it does a good job of being sort of
a generalized mechanism for modeling us
so we use roles and permissions a couple
different ways because again
authorization in a system they're
actually very many different like tiers
or levels of where authorization will be
checked and this could even be within a
a single request into your web server
right so we've kind of realized roles
are a really good kind of coarse-grained
mechanism for doing authorization for
maybe the entire product that your end
user is trying to use right so one of
the customers that we worked with in
coming up with these this modeling and
in this product is a healthcare related
company and basically they have doctors
nurses and patients right that's that's
their roles for all the users in their
system so you know there's certain types
of apps where you have to be a doctor or
nurse to get in and if you're patient
you shouldn't get in ok so that's nice
easy top-level kind of coarse-grained
you know authorization logic so we
figured rolls made it good make good
sense for that then within the
application you might be going to
different feature areas right maybe a
component within the software or a
particular function in the software and
you know you could use roles to model
those but we found permissions also are
a really good model so permissions do a
decent job of kind of giving you the the
notion of if the users allowed to you
know perform some sort of action ok and
you know again that's still kind of
general you can have an external system
where you configure this roles and
permissions you know you map users into
roles and then roles are granted access
to permissions and that made sense that
felt good when we were building this
product but then there's the line that I
talked about where you start to cross
where well now the logic that you're
talking about in terms of authorization
is very business specific and that's
where we decided to stop we said you
know what that is you know domain logic
right about you know maybe in the
medical system about prescribing
medication right so your can can this
user prescribe medication Oh to this
patient but maybe this patient actually
has allergies to the medication that
feels like business logic to me right if
you're building some some medical
software that's the value of your
software that's the business that you're
in so building that logic outside of
that system itself like I said didn't
make sense to me so like I said this is
kind of our conclusion about how
authorization at least in this
you know generalized system we were
trying to build where it should stop and
where the rest of the logic is like I
said just your business logic all right
we built this thing and we're actually
still working on it
and kind of at the end of building it we
we said hey you know what we've just
built something called as man okay so
you know no not not the fusilli Jerry
Seinfeld sort of as man it's a different
one did you guys remember this tool man
from like 10 or 15 years ago that
people's gray hair remember right so
this was a tool that Microsoft built and
it was actually kind of a nice tool
because what it allowed to do is define
a set of roles and you could map users
into the roles and then this tool knew
about your comm components and at the
class level the interface level or the
method level you could then assign what
roles had access or what have what
permissions to use those functions and
this is a nice tool because it was
visual you know somebody could go and
sort of from an administrative
standpoint not a developer go and map
users to the right roles or permissions
to give them access to the functionality
they needed okay so it's actually it's
kind of funny because when we're
building us we didn't really kind of
think of as man but we then in
retrospect realized okay that we model
worked well and so we've kind of
reinvented pretty much that all right so
here's the general architecture that we
end up having when we are you know
building these identity systems and what
you end up with is several different
types of applications you know depending
on what you're trying to build
you could have server-side web
applications JavaScript browser-based
spa style applications
you know native applications mobile
mobile apps for example and of course
you have users using those apps and so
what you typically do is if you want to
know who the user is the authentication
then you you know go set up some sort of
identity as a service right you set up a
security token service that implements
protocols like open ID connect and OAuth
and this gives you the benefit of single
sign-on centralized identity management
and then all the apps they don't have to
worry about authenticating the sort of
outsource it to the identity provider
and that also then protects your web
api's that's great so again that's the
authentication architecture the trap
that most people fall at fall into or
fallen into that I've seen of kind of
like the wrong way to go about doing
authorization is that they say you know
I've already done all this work and
effort of setting up this identity
system centralized that's awesome you
know what now I need to do my
authorization why don't I make that
thing also do my authorization right
somehow Jam authorization information
permissions whatever into this identity
system and then that'll take care of
both its security right take care of
both okay and that's very much the cup
of the few customers that we ended up
seeing that that had gone down that path
ended up being you know problematic
there are several different issues that
come up and I'm going to talk about
those here in a second so this is kind
of the the reminder that not to do that
right the identity system is not your
authorization system right I mean those
semantically mean different things okay
so it's generally a bad idea to try to
overload your authentication system with
permission data here's an example of
that so the job of your identity system
your centralized identity system is to
issue tokens and the tokens represent
the identity of the user and these get
sent around to your apps and or your
api's and in the tokens go claims okay
so we see a token here looks like a JSON
web token and in here are several
groupings if you will of claims
so one grouping up here is the fact that
we have some sort of protocol and
authentication related claims or
information Thanks so who issued this
token right that's needed for trust
things like that we also have
information about the user metadata
about their authentication like when
they authenticated and what they use to
authenticate they used a password and
then there's also this thing called the
audience and the audience indicates
where this token is allowed to be used
okay so this actually looks like an
Access
touken to me that means this is a token
that we used to call api's and this
tokens job or can be used at both maybe
api 1 and api - okay great that's
totally normal what a token looks like
of course we'll also have information
about the user right their identity
information so we'll have a subject
identifier that's the unique ID of the
user and then maybe other attributes
about the user like their name you know
their email if you need that things like
that so these other claims are where it
starts to get a little blurry okay
sometimes I've seen people put
permissions into these tokens okay and
that's like very obvious authorization
information not identity information
right and these permissions may be
things like oh yeah the user can delete
data and manage customers and so on and
so forth okay so there's a bit of a
problem with that right the problem here
is this token can get used at API 1 an
API - ok the permission called delete
data which of those is that appropriate
for ok
usually applications have the notion of
application specific permissions because
maybe they just do different things but
now if we're overloading this token
that's meant to convey the identity of
the user with permission data now it's
not clear you know which context that
permission makes sense okay that's a
little bit of a problem
another type of thing we have in here
are also roles and roles are really kind
of in the gray area here when you're
talking about identity versus
authorization or permissions right so
the role of doctor well let me take a
step back when I think about roles I
kind of think roles in one of two ways
role could be used for identity data or
it could be used to model permissions or
authorization so the roll call doctor to
me feels like identity data so for me
I'm ok with doctor being in here ok but
the role called approver that sounds
more like a permission to me right so it
sounds you know ambiguous as to what
that really means and in what context
does that mean so if you have a role if
you're using roles and they have
like verbs in there chances are you're
using that as a permission or an
authorization role as opposed to an
identity role okay
so again these because the token can be
used at multiple places it may be
ambiguous if these permissions are
applicable at those locations what about
if you get removed from one of these
roles or you have one of these
permissions you know denied what's the
problem well the the app will still have
access to these permissions right it can
still use these because these
permissions are embedded into the token
you have a copy of that data so if you
actually end up deleting in the database
your role or permission or whatever the
token you know it's out of date so the
the kind of like solution to this is
kind of what Windows does is if you're
you know domain admin adds you to a
group you have to log out and log in
again okay so maybe that's not terribly
desirable another problem with this is
of course the amount of size or the
number of roles or permissions that you
might try to put in here right you could
have a thousand roles or a thousand
permissions or probably both permissions
and infinite number of permissions so
there is a physical limit to this you
know token size because it's being sent
over the network right HTTP headers and
whatnot so again the various reasons why
putting permissions and roles in here
are problematic okay so again this is
just showing the same thing the idea is
that this token is meant to be used on
multiple api's all right so yeah here's
your your summary of that for
authorization what you really want to do
is have the token represent the identity
of the user and then you pass that into
something else to actually figure out
your authorization and that's something
else is some sort of permissioning
system okay so
permissions might just be like logic
based on the identity or permissions
might actually be things like in a
database like flags in a database and
the thing that that is needed to
understand here is that this equation
has to have context in what scenario are
you
trying to do something right is it in
API one or API two or you know I can do
certain things in the oncology app but
not in you know the the other part of
the app okay all right so that's
fundamentally our thinking on this your
tokens your identity should just be
identity and permissions should be a
separate thing
so our proposal is to introduce
something else in your ecosystem which
allows you to model these permissions
and we're calling this a policy provider
of some sort it's basically some sort of
engine that knows how to take the
identity as an input as well as the
context of where the identity is trying
to be used and then returned to you as a
result the set of roles and permissions
that you're allowed to to be in okay so
here's the kind of workflow that we're
thinking here as the user logs in from
the identity system you'll of course get
their identity in whatever token you
have and then as that application wants
to go and you know determine the
authorization for the user you go and
contact some sort of policy system and
again this is I'm kind of hand waving
here this could be a centralized system
or just could be a database lookup right
whatever whatever you want that to be
the point is it's separate from the
identity system it's some engine that
will do some sort of mapping for the
identity of the user and the context in
which the user is trying to perform
their operation okay
so then based on that information if
this is like the front end maybe the
front end could then say uh you don't
have this permission therefore you know
all hi to hide or show a button or menu
in the application and then as that
application calls out to other parts of
your system same thing these all will
get the context will get the identity of
the user they each have their own
context and they will then do their own
mapping for that particular system of
what the roles and permissions are for
the user and then what would be really
nice is on top of this some sort of nice
administrative tool where your sis at
men could go and manage this right your
sis at minka go and say hey we have this
new hire there a doctor you know to put
them in that appropriate role or grant
them the appropriate permission
okay that's the idea so this is actually
what we ended up building we ended up
building the this policy server product
it has internally this engine that does
this mapping that's context to where
based on the identity of the user and
the application that they are trying to
access and then what we have are a few
Web API s1 Web API is a management web
api so of course you could build some
sort of management tooling management UI
to go manage these policies these
mappings of users the other thing about
the API is that maybe if you built your
own your own custom user management
workflow or you already have your own
user management tools then you could
simply tap into the API to augment the
underlying policy system and then what
we have is another API which is the
client API which is what your app or API
would connect to to map the user into
their roles and permissions so the
parameter that we pass along here is
we're gonna pass along the claims for
the user and which application cares you
know which which context we're in and
you'll get back these roles and policies
roles and permissions excuse me okay
that's the high level the high level
idea now this probably you're like
thinking this is not rocket science
right we'll probably done this
yourselves or done this ourselves you
know but that's fundamentally the the
problem that we saw is we went to our
customers and saw that they had already
driven this and written their own
version and then some other project
within the same company Oh they'd
written their own kind of flavor of this
as well so that's the motivation behind
sort of standardizing this so from a
programming model and a modeling of
authorization that's fundamentally what
we have is now this this model where the
user comes in we're gonna map them to
roles and permissions based on the app
or the context that they are accessing
so how can your application actually now
tap into this and now once you know the
roles and permissions how do you
actually enforce them within the
application so there are a couple things
we can do here so I have some code to
illustrate this and first and foremost
what I have is if your application wants
to know
you know the roles and permissions as
the user gets mapped to then you need to
have access to this engine of some sort
so what we have here oops
actually first is a application where I
log the user in that was actually a
pretty important important feature to us
is that we wanted this policy system to
be decoupled from the identity system
obviously for the architectural reasons
I mentioned but we didn't want to force
you to use identity server for example
so this policy system and this
programming model obviously couldn't
work for anything if you're using Azure
ad or something else as well so what I
have here is just a really simple login
page to model login the user so you know
if you're type in the username Alice
then hey you're Atlas and so what we're
doing is when we log Alice in will see
that Alice has a unique ID of one that's
the subject claim sub that's Alice is a
user ID if you will right Bob is gonna
be I guess user ID 11 and we have a
third type of user who is user ID 21 I
guess if you're not Alice or Bob you're
somebody else and the idea I think is
this person is going to be end up being
a patient in our hospital system so I
think Alice ultimately I'll map it to a
doctor and Bob will be mapped to a nurse
okay
so I'll run this real quick hit secure
login as Alice great I'm logged in I
have two claims subject and name so now
this application wants to know okay for
this application for the you know this
is going to be my emergency room
application what are the users roles and
permissions so to model that in the you
know reference implementation that I
have here what we have is the policy
provider is just in memory and it is
driven in terms of the mapping rules
based on some configuration out of our
JSON file so what we have is just some
really simple jason that allows us to to
define what roles we are gonna have for
this application so this particular
application
has a doctor role and it allows me to
map which subject identifier to them
okay and we have a nurse for with some
subject identifiers and we have a
patient as well so in the the way we've
done the simple implementation
Frank's implementation here you can map
users based on their user ID or you can
map users based on their identity roles
so remember I was saying we made the
distinction between roles being used for
identity and roles being used for
authorization or permissions so the
assumption here is that if the user logs
in and the identity system says they're
a surgeon okay that's fine the
centralized you know Active Directory
knows that Alice is a surgeon great
maybe that's a group though she's in
that identity information will come to
this application this particular
application maybe it's the emergency
room application it doesn't care if
you're a surgeon or an oncologist or
whatever
we just want a model users in terms of
these three roles doctor nurse and
patient so the role doctor nurse and
patient in this particular application
those are application specific roles
okay and that's how the app is decided
to model its authorization so we're
mapping identity data using identity
data whether it's your unique ID or
maybe your identity roles to an
application specific role then once you
have these application specific roles we
have also the ability to model
permissions so the permissions are the
operations that a user might be
performing in this application and then
as you can see it's a really simple
mapping oh you are gonna map to this
application specific role therefore you
get this application specific permission
so how does your app at runtime now
actually run the mapping okay so that's
the first thing that we have here is you
need some way to be able to invoke this
mapping engine and what we have is the
notion of a service that can go into the
dependency injection system for you to
trigger that so what I have is a policy
server client interface this will go
into the DI system so I gotta go
configure that in a second but the idea
is that your page if you're running
along you just want to know and you say
hey I want to pass this user in wherever
I came from my authentication and I want
to get back the the authorization
results for them and you know again it's
not rock
science here we're just returning a list
of roles and permissions okay so that's
one way to do it so let me go down here
go into my application call my client
I'm gonna say evaluate a sync and then
I'll pass in the user object that will
have been populated from the in this
case the cookie come into my application
and I actually will just show that then
in my view okay
but again the result has like I said the
roles and the permissions so you could
simply take these two collections look
for the one that you need for the
context that you're in in this
particular bit of code and then do your
you know allowed or denied okay so for
this thing to work here I need to put it
into the DI system so I can go to my
startup code and what I have is an
extension method here that will populate
the policy server client service into di
loaded from the data from my
configuration file okay so I run this
assuming Visual Studio complies and it's
not you guys seen that new feature in
Visual Studio the one where it locks all
your files and then you can't actually
rerun yeah you gotta wait no and then
start again okay networked so again I
think I'm logged in as Alice user ID one
if I go to my secure page yeah look at
that so what we are now doing is this is
the data the claims that are coming from
your cookie we take those and we invoke
the policy server engine and we get back
our app specific roles and permissions
okay real simple right okay so that's
one way to tap into the policy system is
you just call it you get back these two
lists and then your application logic
you know does whatever it needs to based
on that okay another very common pattern
though the people would like so this is
a different way to react from the or
have your application you know respond
to the authorization information is we
can use the good old authorized
attribute okay so the authorized
right with rolls equals people use this
all the time all right this is kind of
your coarse-grained role based
authorization so how do we do that well
for this to work this authorized
attribute is calling the is in roll
method for the current user in the
application right well does my current
user have a claim for the roll no write
the code down here this is just showing
what came back from the mapping right
but for the isn't roll check to work my
claims off of the current user object
have to have a roll so what I kind of
need to do is take the results of this
and populate the claims on the current
user for the current request okay so if
you guys were my workshop the other day
we talked about the concept of claims
transformation right the cookie only has
a couple claims you're now running the
policy engine mapping those to a bunch
of new claims and merging them together
and then for the duration of this
request you have them all kind of in one
place so for this to work we need some
sort of claims transformation and that's
another little widget we've added here
into our our little library okay so what
we can do is do a use policy server
claims transformation and it will go off
and do that mapping so if I rerun this
now we should see then on the secure
page yeah look at this so now we have
the original two claims that came from
the cookie and what we're doing is we're
running the policy engine mapping to
roles and permissions and then we're
actually creating a new identity and
merging into the principle if you guys
are know are familiar with the identity
and I principle interfaces and the
claims identity and claims principle
that a principal is the user object it
can have multiple identities so we're
just putting in two two different
identities one from the original cookie
and a new one that we created coming
from this claims transformation so now
that we do have a role of doctor I
probably should have done this a second
ago I should be able to go into my app
and now do the you know nurses only
action
for example okay and I don't want to
leave that comment uncommented okay cool
so now I should be able to do the nurses
only action and actually because I'm a
doctor right now I don't think this will
work yeah exactly we got access tonight
but if we log out log back in and say
Bob okay Bob different identity bob has
different set of roles and permissions
then great that one works okay so that's
just a different way to capitalize upon
this mapping layer this abstraction that
we're setting up to map the user to
roles and permissions specific to this
application another approach for
utilizing the authorization is to
actually tap into something more
sophisticated so asp.net core has a
brand new authorization system and
unfortunately it's called the policy
based authorization system so we now
have the term being used in two contexts
here so my apologies for the confusion
as we all know naming is hard so the
idea is that the the mapping layer that
we have in the JSON file that's the
policy server feature and what we want
to do then is take the results of those
policies the the roles and permissions
and run it against this more
sophisticated policy based authorization
what makes the policy based
authorization system a little bit more
appealing than the role based is that it
gives you a level of indirection it
gives you a place to put some code that
has your rules if the users allowed or
denied and you put that in a centralized
place rather than you putting nurse and
doctor and then oh I also have to put
the nurse and doctor string into the UI
and any other place I need to run this
rule you're duplicating that sort of
logic here the policy based system form
asp net core allows you to build your
logic by defining what's called the
policy right and so what we can do is we
can build a policy in this case
prescribe medication and what I want
this policy to do is first check to see
if the users authenticated right you
shouldn't be prescribing medication if
we don't know who you are
and then second of all we're now
depending on a claim that was produced
by the user mapping layer right so
that's the policy server or Jason
mapping that I talked about
okay so we're merging an asp net core
policy with the results of the policy
server mapping so i can build this
policy and then the beauty here is that
down on the bottom right if you can see
that is that the authorized attribute
allows you to just put the name of the
asp.net core policy and it will
basically give you that level of
indirection to run that authorization so
i think i have this code somewhere in
here yeah here we go so I have a perform
surgery let's call it well I'll just
leave it there so perform surgery asp
net core policy and it is triggered off
of the perform surgery mapping that had
come from my you know my my policies
here in the jason file okay so now that
I have a perform surgery I can go back
to my home controller and now here we go
we have another action method that
presumably I think only doctors can do
okay so if I run this
secur let's see let's do Bob first okay
if I scroll down Bob should not be able
to perform surgery okay make sense come
back in Alice right and Alice should be
good to go there we go okay all right so
that's just a quick look at the asp.net
core policy system like I said it's kind
of nice you have a nice little place to
put your logic about the user
centralized one place and then you can
just reference it from your your
application code another way to
reference this from the application code
is obviously we can use the authorized
attribute one of the complaints though
is that the authorized attribute doesn't
help you with the unit testing so if
this code right here needs to be unit
testable you need to you know it would
be nice to be to go in and and you know
write your unit test and pick up this
logic so one more thing you can do
actually I won't bother writing the code
it's in the slides is that you can
actually inject a service called the
authorization service this is coming
from asp.net core and this asp.net core
service authorization service allows you
to programmatically check with this
authorized call and you can say
authorize the user and you say the name
of the policy okay
so again the string on the right there
prescribed medication is basically then
going finding the policy up on the top
left which is then checking a permission
which we mapped from our our JSON file
okay the nice thing about now that you
can do this programmatically is that you
could also then not only enforce your
authorization logic at the action method
that's really performing the action but
you can also then leverage this other
places in your application and the UI is
probably a good obvious choice here
because you about you know if the user
is not allowed to perform the action why
don't we hide the button in the first
place okay or the menu so this
particular style of doing this is you
know debatable whether or no it's the
best way but this is a you can do
dependency injection in your razor views
right so you can inject the exact same
interface I just showed you or probably
if you were really trying to do this in
a cleaner way you would inject this
still into your control
and then when you're building up your
view model just have a flag that says to
them to the raiser page whether the
button should be you know shown or
hidden okay so what I've shown you is
kind of a nice little you know combining
of the two patterns the policy server
mapping engine to give you roles and
permissions and then tapping into the
asp net core policy system to get the
benefit of you know using the attribute
or using the authorization service okay
the only downside about doing that this
way is I think in my JSON file I had
like four or five permissions but for
anything real right you could probably
imagine 20 or more permissions and I
don't want to have to come in here and
define a policy in the asp.net core
policy system for every one of my
permissions that's you know in my
permission system so it turns out that
the authorization system itself from
Microsoft is extensible they actually
have a policy provider I think is the
name of it and what happens is at
runtime whenever your application like
for example down here when we trigger
the pot the asp net core policy with
that string in this case perform surgery
what happens is the asp net core system
goes and looks for the service and di
that will find the policy and by default
it finds the policies based on the the
static mapping i've done here
well that interface that policy provider
itself itself is replaceable in the DI
system so what you can do is instead of
using the built in policy definitions
you can implement it yourself or you can
leverage the one that we've done that
will implement it for you so what we
have is off of our di system where we
configure the fact that we want to use
policy server we then have a little
authorization permission policy so this
registers our custom policy provider and
now our custom policy provider what
happens is when the policy is being
requested ok we go and basically look
for
matching permission name from the claims
okay and also we do this not by looking
at the user claims the in-memory user
claims instead we do this by actually
calling directly into the the policy
server client interface which is the
same one I showed you here that you
could call directly what that basically
means is that it's actually calling this
is still running I don't think it is
that means I don't need to do the claims
transformation anymore okay
so actually for this to work I can even
take the claims transformation out okay
so I'm just showing you different styles
about how you can you know actually
enforce this authorization so you know
maybe one you want to trigger off the
user the other you want to do this
policy system so if I ruin that
correctly just double check that I
didn't miss anything so I took up the
claims transformation I wired up the
policy provider and now I got rid of the
the one I statically did the mapping for
I come back in here and I'm still Alice
so I should still be able to perform
surgery yep and again checking Bob here
yeah good
all right okay
one last idea one last technique I
suppose for tapping into the asp.net
core policy system is they actually
provide a mechanism for being a little
bit more sophisticated with your your
asp net core policies so let me go back
here so this policy that we defined in
the top left this asp net core policy
the main input into the logic is the
user so the logic only is looking at
what claims the user has to decide if
you are allowed or denied to prescribe
medication that may be fine for some
logic but in other scenarios you might
actually need more information okay so
what asp net core provides is the
ability to create what's called a custom
requirement and a custom requirement
allows you to model additional data that
is an input into your authorization
logic so in this case we have an example
of a medication requirement and so this
is where what we want to do is you know
we said oh maybe nurses or doctors can
prescribe medication but maybe depending
on the type of medication and the amount
of medication that's not good enough
okay so maybe for you know non you know
aspirin or something a nurse can
prescribe that but for morphine the
doctor has to prescribe it something
like that okay
so s peanut core actually has a way to
do this you create this class called a
requirement it models your dynamic data
that needs to be this input into the
authorization you create what's called a
handler and this handler is an
authorization Handler of your custom
requirement class that's up here in the
top right and then there's a method in
the middle here that you have to
implement it called handle requirement
async okay and what gets handed in to
this method is the user and then that
requirement object and that requirement
object is what has the medication and
the amount so now you have the user and
that additional data and you can go run
whatever logic you want to so now this
is actually an interesting combination
of we're kind of beginning on the
borderline of using the role and
permission
mapping from the JSON file but then
sprinkling in some additional
application logic here we're kind of
mixing the two okay so in this case I
don't know what do we have here if you
have the permission to prescribe the
medication great and it's a low amount
fine you're good but if it's a high
amount you need to be in this case a
doctor for example okay and I guess if
the medication is a placebo then yeah
sure you can prescribe that too okay so
that's the idea now the way this
actually gets triggered in the
application is one this class has to go
into the dependency injection system
okay
so this goes into the DI system and then
from your application you can only
trigger these programmatically right you
can't use the declarative authorized
attribute because you need to create the
the requirements object on the fly so
you would in your action method where
we're prescribing medication create the
requirement object call in to the
authorized method if it comes back and
says you're good to go the method
succeeds if not you tell the user to go
away okay and you can either use
challenge or forbid those are the two
built-in methods in asp net core so
that's an example of kind of mixing the
two the two styles if you will okay I
think what's really interesting about
this is that if you notice how we
actually implemented this how did I know
if you could just do the kind of the
coarse-grained prescribed medication
check well if you look because this
class is in the DI system itself can
take dependencies on other services from
the DI system so you can actually take a
dependency on the policy server client
interface and call into it to do the
mapping or again you could may even have
other stuff in the database right other
Flags permissions columns in the
database that have you know yes as a
knows and says whether or not the user
is allowed to so kind of an interesting
mix of the two any more than this though
I mean even this I'm actually a little
on the fence about personally because
now we're really starting to blend some
business logic in here and this is where
like I said that we decided deliberately
policy server to stop we realized that
you know would it make sense to
externalize this type of logic would it
make sense to take this type of logic
and go put it in some other system in
some XML file that have these rules yeah
I don't know because then what would
have to happen is if at runtime when
you're invoking the business logic to
prescribe medication then you have to
take all the data of the context not
only the user but now the amount and the
medication and maybe even some more data
out of your database export all of that
to this other system and have it run the
logic to produce a yes or a No okay and
that's why we thought that in building a
product or building any kind of
framework to satisfy this pattern I
think there's a point at which the
framework can generalize only so much
and anything beyond that is probably a
mistake and it makes more sense to put
that kind of logic like I said right
here in your business code okay one last
thing just to mention a very common
pattern that I think tends to be a nice
thing to do is making sure that if the
user is not authenticated at all they're
not allowed to get into your application
so in MVC in asp net core you can set up
a global policy asp.net core policy
where you basically require that the
user be logged in when you build that
policy you could add any additional
requirements on the user such as being
in a particular role so this is another
good example of where you know for the
coarse-grained check like do you have
access to the app or not maybe the you
know only in the emergency room software
the the doctor and the nurse should be
accessing it so you can set up a global
authorization policy for asp.net MVC
core it's a little weird how you do it
unfortunately but you have to build this
builder in your MVC options when you're
loading up MVC in the DI system and you
pop in your requirements there and then
you set that up as a global authorized
filter still I think this is a generally
a good practice to put in
so like I said we kind of already talked
about the conclusion here but this is
basically the conclusion that we had is
that for coarse-grained type of logic
rolls make make a lot of sense for
feature access within an application
roles or permissions combination of the
two make a lot of sense to externalize
into some you know helper library to
help you out but beyond that it really
starts to feel forced to try to have an
external system you know incorporate
whatever your business logic might be so
that's the conclusion we came to and
that pretty much is sort of the the
mental progression and that we went
through when building policy server
there a couple of resources here my
colleague Dominic has a blog post that
kind of talks about the background of
this there's some more information about
the asp.net core authorization system
and there is the link to the github repo
for the sample code that I just showed
you I think we have a few minutes left i
if there are any questions yeah question
right so I think the comment is about
administration of this so if you really
are built using different components for
your authorization that feels scattered
okay well if you build an administrative
UI to aggregate all that together then
from the end users perspective it won't
seem scattered we do that all the time
and that's one of the reasons why the
main in the product that we build our
management piece has an API so that you
can then call that so your aggregated UI
can call one system for one type of
thing and one type of you know another
system for another type of thing again I
think that's the nature of the beast
right because authorization like I said
is it done at many tiers even within a
single request into a web server there's
lots of different stages where different
authorization might need to run and it's
different like scope if that makes sense
okay yeah I can just show you real
quickly the the the policy server
product kind of a thinking behind it
here is the admin UI that we have for
managing policies in the policy server
product and this is the the pattern is
exactly the same I just described the
idea is that we are gonna have policies
and you can then for a policy you
typically use a policy to model and
applications authorization requirements
so here's the exact emergency room
sample that we had from before and you
can come in here and define roles and
permissions and when you define roles
and permissions you can come in here and
say you know what identities map to this
particular application specific role and
then based on that application specific
role you then map which you know app
roles can access various permissions so
it's pretty much the same thing I just
showed you this is just centralized in a
database there's an API behind this
management UI that API is the same one
that you could call from your aggregated
UI if you wanted and they're auditing
features as well on this as well as
multi tendancy support you know you may
have two different tenants with
different sets of users that you
obviously map differently another
interesting feature we have though is
the ability to build a hierarchy of
policies so it might be very common that
you have a couple different applications
that actually have shared roles so the
idea is that when we built this we
needed to be able to support that so you
can define a policy and at the root
policy you define the shared roles you
know all your applications in the
hospital system have these roles and
these users map to it okay but at the
top level you don't really have any
permissions because what's being modeled
is the hospital not any one app and so
then we can do is create a child policy
underneath it and the child policy is
what actually models the application it
by virtue of being a child policy you
inherit all the role mappings but then
it's at the child policy where you
define your permissions and do your
assignments of roles to these features
okay so like I said an important feature
to implement once we realize that these
policies have this hierarchy and that
the nodes and the hierarchy don't have
to model an application it can be really
modeled whatever you want it to so we
took this one step further and started
prototyping and saying hey what if the
actual policy is modeling a resource in
your system so let's say you have a
medical record system and you have rules
about you know which roles can can do
which permissions to you know operations
on medical records and then you actually
create a policy in here to represent an
instance of a room in a medical record
in this system and at this particular
instance you then map particular users
into roles then you have the ability to
have two different medical records with
two different users having different
levels of permission for example okay so
that's kind of an interesting feature
here now the interesting thing is when
the application connects when it invokes
the policy it has to pass a path to the
policy so the users in the app they're
trying to access policy you know one two
three and so the app will connect and
say hey I need to execute under the
hospital system the medical records app
what are the permissions for this user
for you know record one two three for
example anyway just a little bit of
thinking behind the commercial product
and and what that offers beyond just
what I showed you here and the really
simple you know role and permission
mapping okay
yes question
so so the way I think about this is that
rolls and there's an exception to this
but rolls generally are owned by the
application right that might in my
emergency room software knows about the
rolls because it knows the types of
users doctor nurse and patient it also
owns the permissions okay right because
it's it's implementing these features
right when you go into then manage what
you're doing is you're mapping users
onto the rolls okay and we have
multi-tenancy support so if I'm the
manager or the admin of ten at one I'm
only going to map my users to these to
these roles and if I'm the admin of
tenant to map different you know my ten
or two users to those roles you might
also want to create a grouping of users
for that tenant so instead of mapping
one by one you create your own grouping
and assign that's also possible that's
also done with a role but it's a tenant
specific role as opposed to an
application specific role anyway that's
detail so that's how the mapping happens
so I'm kind of missing your question oh
and see everything that there yes yeah
so actually I should mention the UI were
showing you we have a couple different
you know versions of the product we have
the basic version and we have the
Enterprise version this is just the
basic version the more the back-end is
all implemented for that kind of slicing
and dicing of queries the Enterprise
version of our UI is just not done yet
okay yeah okay so that's basically like
I said our conclusion on how
authorization you know could be done
it's definitely a challenge and a
complicated processor or a requirement
to meet but the idea behind can a
generalizing and in building something
out of it is so that you know everybody
doesn't have to reinvent this wheel you
know over and over okay all right well
thank you have a good party tonight
right this is our party night okay
[Applause]